[Applause]
thank you so much for being here
i imagine that's just what your life is
like these days wherever you go
people cheering applauding no but you
know i just had the through
almost the thrill of my life i just met
mick from the clash backstage
you had never met before no no i'm not
very rock and roll you know
so um yeah that was not true that's not
well first of all i was very excited
yeah i tricked him into playing one of
my guitars backstage you know i can sell
it on ebay
uh so much to talk about i have not the
last time you were here
you had just begun your promotional uh
you know painting the queen
for the queen but you had not won your
oscar yet so congratulations
that was the thrilling moment for people
watching it i imagine for you
it was fantastic it was it was a moment
when some life stood still really for
that
that second it's very strange when the
um and i've been there a couple of times
they opened the envelope and oh
it's not me let's go for a drink you
know and this time
it's bad when you do that instantly
though is that when you stand up
or take out a flask right there that's
not good
um so that was a great moment i would
think so and now
you know this this book in the frame and
this is
your your life in words but also no
life i might say no no not your whole
life a little bit back for later
yes that's good that's good because
there's a lot of videos a lot more to
come but one of the things i loved and i
don't want this to make me sound stupid
but there's a lot of pictures here
which are yeah you know and words are
hard uh
but striking pictures i always go for
the pictures when i look at
a biography on autobiography i go
straight for the pictures so i thought
you know what i'm going to do a book
with a whole load of pictures in
and you are so open about your life here
you're obviously
very comfortable just sharing everything
that's happened well i keep a few
secrets back as i say i
haven't um i haven't totally dished the
dirt there's some so there's more to
come there's more different people
too yeah so that's quite a lot of it in
there well there are things in here that
i'd be nervous about if i were in the
same situation
you you talk a little bit about your
parents sex life and i'm thinking oh my
god that's just
that my mind explodes the very concept
is it weird that people hate to think
their parents having sex
i don't think that's weird at all i
think that's health
i think it's weird if they think about
it too much darling yes i have
something to tell you yes that's how you
got here
no no
he was a rabbit just think about it
it's a magical rabbit i'm told with what
a rabbit it's a wand and there's a fairy
and there's a cabbage patch i don't want
to get into the whole thing
it was all explained to me when i was 38
but you talk in this book it's amazing
you're uh
you were in in the movie caligula which
is one of the uh
more disgusting films sexually uh wow
out there movies
uh and the sets i remembered were were
very sexual
everything about it and you invited your
mom to visit you on the set of caligula
well i always took my mom whenever i
went on location anywhere i took my mom
because she she'd never traveled you
know she was a she was a working class
girl from london and she always dreamed
to travel
so when i finally did start traveling
making movies i would always bring my
mom on set
so you know caligula was made in rome in
italy so i very much wanted her to visit
i had a nice apartment she could stay
with me and also my mum was so cool
because she
you know she would just sit and chat to
anyone on the set whatever set it was on
and um you know on caligula there she
was sort of sitting between two enormous
golden fallacies you know
right on her and chatting and no one on
caligula ever wore clothes
you know it was like weird if someone
came on set wearing anything
so she'd sit chatting away to a naked
extra
so anyway you know what do you do yeah
have you tried clothing yeah very cool
she was
she was very she was very good very cool
for a sort of basically an uncool woman
who
you know wasn't a sort of sophisticated
woman really but
but in this book you talk about how much
you travel
you've been all over the world countless
times you've had all these adventures i
think it's neat that you would include
your mom like that
in these adventures yeah well yes i say
she she'd always dreamt of traveling so
it was great to give her that
opportunity
we have photos i just want to show a few
pictures from the book and
there's all kinds of photos in here so
we can't even do justice very uh some
very sexy uh photographs here i hope you
don't mind us showing them here you are
i love this photograph
[Applause]
gentlemen please was this was this for a
magazine
no no i lived with a very good
photographer called james which
wedge for four years and and we did a
lot of sort of private
erotic work together and um that wasn't
even for a magazine that was just no no
no they were not going to do that
let's do this sure why don't i wear
black stockings and
yeah um it's raining out let's do this
uh
no we we did and and some of our work
together is in the book he's a wonderful
photographer
we have a picture here this is actually
your mom uh
is visiting you here and what we noticed
is
in the background i'm pretty sure that's
a a certain kind of plant that's growing
uh just behind my dad
your mom you keep saying she's not cool
she is the coolest mom
well your pot plant needs marriage it
needs more water there
no she had no idea and she's a gardener
you know she loved to garden but she had
she has a green thumb i tell you yeah
she
had absolutely no idea what that plot
what is that plant darling oh we won't
talk
i've never seen that one before what is
it oh it's a kind of geranium mum
yes oh does it flower no not normally
can we smoke it mama please uh and then
in a similar vein we you took a
photograph very uninhibited this is
i think you uh experimenting with lsd
and this is a photograph that
someone took maybe you're so sex drugs
and rock and roll aren't you i mean
he goes straight for that yeah that's me
all over yeah yeah
there are nice pictures of trees in here
but i thought no one wants to see that
um yes it was the the very beginning of
the one and only acid trip i ever took
which was absolutely fantastic i have to
say
no no no no no no no you know what
that's
that's what i look like after a big meal
so it's the same
pretty much has the same value as a
thanksgiving dinner
um anyway so it was wonderful but
never again only that one time too
extreme just really too much
i have to ask you about this i you i i
know that there's so many fantastic
stories about your life in the theater
experimental theater and you have great
stories about being in the west end
of london and of course things change
and things become more gentrified and
fancy but we're talking about the times
when the west end of london was uh
was a dodgy place oh my god it still is
it's i don't know if you've been there
on saturday night recently i mean it's a
wild it's a wild wild place or west end
no you're often doing you know i was
doing chekhov and
you know all the football supporters
would be outside going ah snow
ass no arsenal you know into uh
19th century uh russia but i had some
great experience
so you're trying to do a period play yes
in 19th century russia and you're trying
to do this you know
uh this this classic work and then
outside it's the 1960s and all hell was
breaking away yes definitely absolutely
um you know i did a play in
about the rock and roll business called
teeth and smiles
written by david hare and i was playing
some janice joplin character
and i'm a terrible singer i can't sing
at all so that was a bit of a
you know dodgy thing for me singing on
stage but anyway i'm about to go on for
my last entrance and i hear this and
my a dressing room overlooks the back
alley um
where the dress is where the stage door
is i hear this incredible crashing and
banging and noise and
and everything and i hope mick's
listening to this because he'll
appreciate
it and i look out the back and and
that's where all the the trash cans are
and they're climbing out of one of the
trash cans
is this completely drunken guy totally
old as we say in england and i like it
and uh covered now in trash and he's got
pinstripe suit on and a complete madman
so i think oh you know some drunk as
usual saturday night in london
so i go waiting to go on for my last
entrance and then i hear the crashing
and the banging
coming in through the stage door and i
think oh my god he's broken into the
theater
and then i hear the crashing and the
banging coming up the stairs outside my
dressing room
and then the crashing and the banging
stops right outside my dressing room and
i bang bang back
ellen ellen come on ellen
and i opened the door and it's keith
moon the dress
moon keith the insane who drummer keith
moon yeah
my childhood hero exactly yeah standing
there and he was the man in the trash
can
and i go oh you said hello darling oh
yeah you're fantastic in this play
i said oh hello keith it's really nice
to meet you i'm very honoured
you know thank you for coming to visit
yes all right darling
so and i said i've got to leave you now
because i've got to go on stage
don't worry i'll come with you
this is great this would be amazing i
know it takes some explaining in this
play yeah oh
no keith don't you stay here no
it's all right i'll come and play in
your band it'll be good you know
and uh i said to my i'm i'm so idiotic
this is why i say i'm not rock and roll
if i was rock and roll i'd say yeah come
on man right right just be historic
instead i went oh no no you can't it's a
theater we don't do that sort of thing
you know
and i re i've one of my great regrets is
not having appeared on stage
with keith moon yes yes that's fantastic
well uh uh i i we're out of time which
is always a shame because i could talk
to you for nine hours
and i hope to do that someday when i
break into your home
uh in the frame uh helen mirren my life
in words and pictures is available it's
really a fantastic book
uh it is such a thrill for me when you
stop by thank you so much really an
[Applause]
honor